Let's go next to our color from the uh, nine
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from nine one seven.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Hey Don, this is, I love Israel in regards
to like what are your thoughts on like I've
been noticing a lot of supposed liberal people
like or leftists that are pushing this rushing
like anti Russia gate thing.
To me doing all that and like I'm just curious
what your thoughts on like, do you find that
incredibly damaging?
Are they still doing it?
I mean, listen, I don't watch, I don't watch
any of the liberal shows, but I thought that
they were done with that because the, we got
the Mueller report already, didn't we?
Well, I, it's not even just, just still pushing
the whole like, uh, anti like, um, maybe am
I explaining it right?
But like, yeah, just pushing like that it's
this conspiracy and that's a big failure when
I just find it really bizarre that anyone
on the left or anyone that's like just not
a Trump supporter, anytime would be like totally
ignore it.
Which is probably the biggest scandal I would
say in modern US history.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I can't speak to what the
motivations are for what other shows do you
know?
I don't really watch them, but at this point,
I don't even know like what I guess people
could say, Oh, it was all overblown from the
beginning or something like that.
But it's like, listen, we got a report that
was extremely damaging to the president.
He has successfully kind of inoculated himself
from consequences and we'll see if reelection
continues, uh, to keep him inoculated.
But we had, you know, convictions, indictments,
prison time, Donald Trump found to have behave,
meet all three criteria for obstruction on,
I think it's eight to 14 possible obstructive
acts.
I don't know.
I mean listen, uh, there's not any news related
to it right now, so I'm not even talking about
it.
I don't know what it is that people are like,
what does the, I don't even know what there
is to cover about it at this point, you know?
But again, I can't see, I don't want to judge
what other shows are doing w if I haven't
seen it.
Okay.
I appreciate that.
And, uh, if I could have one other question
and I'm sure other people have had the SSP,
I'm sure you might've heard or seen clips
or watch.
Did you see the Dave Rubin the interview?
I did.
And you know, I've not covered it only because
I've not had the, um, emotional willpower
to sit through it all to pull the clips.
But it was basically a combination.
I mean [inaudible] it struck me as Dave Ruben
doing exactly what the debate moderators have
done so far, which is he questions up with
right-wing framings and then Tulsi Gabard
answering them, buying into those right wing
framings rather than pointing out that the
questions themselves are a huge part of the
problem.
It was really bad from what I saw.
Yeah.
I'm just curious like where, where's she?
Obviously she knows she's not going to get
the nomination.
You would think so.
I mean, it will only someone who is completely
diluted would be pulling 1% and not even in
a all of the debates anymore and believing
that they're going to be the president or
even the nominee.
I assume you're right about that.
I just think that it's not even that, I think
she's like angling for something else.
Either some kind of spoil, a third party run
or who the hell knows?
Some bizarre Trump like last minute thing
grabbing her, putting, you know, like, so
I just found that interview really disturbing.
Wait, now I've not heard of this before.
You're saying maybe she's angling to be, to
replace Mike Pence as Trump's running mate?
I think that might be a little bit [inaudible].
Yeah, I don't know if that's likely.
I don't know that, that
okay in any way whatsoever.
But you know, there's always been little towels,
uh, with TLC over the years.
Like especially like towards her tweets and
like, oh we got to support Trump.
Like immediately after he announced being
won.
No little things like that had been little
red herrings about her.
Uh, I always noticed too, anytime you mentioned
something bad about her, the people that usually
come out full force on Twitter are not people
on the left.
Yeah, man, I hate my hatred mail episode this
week was from a Tulsi supporter supporter,
which is crazy cause usually it's just like
right wing clowns that send the hatred mail.
But all right, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
All right, take care.